today on the matt walsh show a
two-year-old child and her family has
kicked off a united flight because she
wouldn't wear a mask we'll discuss
why masking children is an especially
pointless cruel and cowardly move so
much that it manages to stand out amid
all the other pointless cruel and
cowardly things happening right now in
relation to covid also five headlines
including bill gates telling us that we
cannot go back to normal for a while you
know even over a year and his opinion is
supposed to matter about this for some
reason also the cleveland indians have
solved racism by changing their name and
in our daily cancellation i will cancel
jill biden
one of many jill biden cancellations yet
to come something tells me all of that
and more coming up today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well we know that business owners have
met a lot of challenges to put it mildly
this year um and one of the greatest
challenges that no matter what year it
is uh one of the greatest challenges
that you face as a business owner
is putting together a good hr team and
it's just it's really hard to run a
company if you don't have a good hr team
when running a business hr issues can
absolutely kill you you've got wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations tons of
red tape to navigate
and if you don't uh if you don't really
specialize in that area it could be
really difficult to do and hr manager
salaries are not cheap an average of
seventy thousand dollars a year we're
talking about
and that's why it's great you have bam b
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
and they were created specifically for
small businesses you can get a dedicated
hr manager craft hr policy maintain your
compliance do all that stuff all for
just 99 a month so you can pay 99 a
month or 70 000 a year seems like an
easy choice with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest asset biggest strength and asset
you get your dedicated hr managers
available by phone email real-time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and they help you manage your
employees on a day-to-day basis again
they're doing all that for just 99 a
month uh month to month no hidden fees
you can cancel anytime so you're not
getting locked into something you don't
want to be a part of but you do want to
be a part of this
bambi can help with all of your issues
and you can get a free hr audit today i
would really recommend doing that what
you got to do though is go to bambi.com
walsh right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com walsh spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh you know it's long
been clear to anyone with a discerning
mind that many of the measures we've
seen ostensibly meant to curb the virus
are actually just for show they are at
best
psychological protections
designed not to make people not not to
make people safer but to make people
feel like they are safer you know they
might be like into the signs you see in
restaurant bathrooms that say
employees must wash hands before
returning to work hopefully the
employees already know to wash their
hands if they don't know about that
basic hygiene practice probably the
sign's not going to do much good
and you already have food poisoning
anyway but the sign is there just to
make you feel like the employees are
practicing good hygiene whether they
actually are or not
a video went viral over the weekend
which reveals i think the charade in
poetic fashion an unnamed
doj official can be seen preparing to
walk
onto the stage for a press conference
right before walking onto the stage he
puts on his face mask then he travels
from the side of the stage to the podium
and takes it off to speak so he has it
on for all of about 10 seconds it's
absurd
but in fairness to the bureaucrat in the
video it's really no different from the
now common practice of wearing a mask as
you walk through a restaurant
only to take it off and speak loudly at
your table for 90 minutes you are least
likely to spread covet while walking
quietly to your table yet that's the
precise time when you're made to wear
the mask there's no scientific reason
for this except in the sense that
a placebo effect is in its way a
scientific phenomenon
the problem one of them anyway
is that the charade around coven
the many placebos put in place
often go beyond merely annoying and
venture into outright cruelty the
cruelty for example of telling
restaurants they can't even have outdoor
dining thereby thereby dooming many of
them along with their employees and
owners to financial ruin even while
allowing as we saw last week movie
studios to have large catered lunches in
the same parking lot where the
restaurants you just destroyed were
having their outdoor dining that you
just said was dangerous
that's not just hypocritical and
arbitrary it's monstrous
the people responsible are sociopaths
who care for nothing and about no one
as long as they can project the
appearance that they're doing something
um
but
when it comes to theatrical but cruel
and ineffective coveted safety measures
near the top of the list
has to be the requirement that kids
especially very young children
wear masks
so we've seen episodes like this play
out many times over the last several
months
but this latest incident has gotten
special attention for good reason i
think a young family mother father and
daughter kicked off a united airlines
flight
and initially banned they said from
future flights because the daughter
wouldn't wear a mask
the daughter is two years old i say
again two years old
now before we play the footage from the
plane here is the mother
eliz orbin
talking about their experiences when
they attempted to take a united flight
from denver to newark and here's what
she had to say
we just got kicked off the flight
because our two-year-old would not put
on a mask and we tried i mean i'm gonna
put a video on
and they're sending all of our bags and
edeline's car seat to new york
and we're banned off of united forever
because a two-year-old would not put on
a mask
so they kicked them off the flight
banned them
and still sent their bags to their
destination like i said cruelty she says
here that they tried to get the child to
wear the mask
but she just wouldn't do it indeed they
did in fact as you can see in the video
if anything they tried too much
if you can fault the family at all in
this situation it's for being too
compliant if anything
though i don't fault them or blame them
because it's difficult for families to
navigate this insanity you know and i
would know as someone who has two
toddlers and two other young children
it's very difficult we're being put in
very difficult situations anyway here's
what happened on the plane watch
okay
[Music]
we're over here holding this mask on her
face i'm sorry
and i took that opportunity and i ran
with her to see this i'm literally
covering her face
this is compliance i'm literally holding
over my daughter's face this is
compliance right here
we can't force her she's literally
holding it and she's crying
you're gonna do this to us
yeah wow
all right let's go
okay so then they get kicked off the uh
the plane they were so desperate
to get the two-year-old to wear the mask
that the father was initially holding
the mask over the child's face as she
squirmed to get away
but which i wouldn't recommend doing by
the way but that wasn't good enough and
they were kicked off the flight and
humiliated anyway
this of course is total madness
uh for several reasons let's let's
establish just two of them
number one
have you ever tried to get a
two-year-old to wear like a hat or
gloves in the winter time
even just getting them into the gear is
like trying to force a cat to take a
bubble bath with them squirming and
fighting and kicking to get away and
once you manage to get them into their
eskimo suit they will immediately begin
shedding all the pieces as soon as they
get outside hat comes off one glove a
boot you know they're they're they're
strewn somehow across like a mile even
though the kid wasn't even a mile away
it's all off and then of course they cry
because they're too cold and you have to
go back inside 90 minutes of preparation
for nine seconds of fun that's parenting
in a nutshell but the point is if if you
can't get a two-year-old to wear a hat
or gloves
even when it's cold outside and they at
least partially understand why they're
supposed to wear that stuff
you aren't going to get them to wear a
piece of cloth over their face
especially when they have not the
slightest clue why they have to
of course every time i talk about this i
invariably hear from some proud parent
somewhere who says hey i have a two and
a half year old and he wears the mask
without a problem what's what's the
issue with your kids
well good for you
or maybe not because if your
two-year-old does wear the mask either
he's naturally one of the most
remarkably compliant young children on
planet earth
which may not be as good as it sounds in
the long run or
you have successfully scared him so
badly that he wants to wear it because
he thinks he'll die or get screamed at
if he doesn't
and i'm guessing that most young
children who wear the mask without a
problem fit more into that latter
category
the fact is that most normal children at
that age if they have parents who are
not willing to bully and terrify them
won't wear the mask
and for whatever my amount of time they
do wear it they're going to be chewing
it
licking it doing all kinds of other
gross things with the mask
and it will quickly make them far more
susceptible to germs than they would
have been without it
that's the first point second point
if we're supposed to follow the science
why aren't we doing it here children are
not at all likely to spread the virus
this is the whole reason why shutting
down schools is such a monumentally
terrible idea new york city shut down
schools a few weeks ago when the
positivity rate the general population
of the whole city supposedly had reached
three percent
but the positivity rate at school
were somewhere around point two percent
not two percent point two percent
what this means is that children are
only rarely contracting the virus and
even more rarely spreading it
and a study just published out of
iceland
involving 40 000 people confirms this
national geographic reports report just
came out uh yesterday says this 40 000
person study found that children under
15 were about half as likely as adults
to be infected
and only half as likely as adults to
transmit the virus to others almost all
the chronovirus transmissions to
children
came from adults
so
half is likely to be infected
and half as likely to transmit it
so so then what's the likelihood that a
toddler with no symptoms
both has the virus
and will spread it if she does have it
very small but even that doesn't tell
the whole story because we can probably
assume that the rare child who does
spread the virus
likely is symptomatic when they do that
just seems like the most likely thing
the chances of an asymptomatic child
spreading the virus must be even tinier
than these numbers than indicate
point being
that toddler on the plane
is almost certainly not going to get you
sick i mean there's a chance it's just
not a very high chance
toddlers walking by you on the street
or sitting within proximity of you for a
few minutes somewhere or even less
likely
and yet toddlers across the country on
planes and off planes are forced to wear
the mask why
well the answer is what we've already
said it's a charade it's theater
the point is to make people feel better
feel safer feel like something is being
done
but
it's certainly not making the children
feel better
you know we're only confusing them at
best traumatizing them at worst
so this is all about the adults
that child had to be muzzled and then
thrown off the plane so that the adults
around her could have their hysterical
paranoia assuaged adults
are making children suffer
so that they the adults can feel safer
this is the exact opposite
of how society is supposed to work
we're supposed to be the calming voices
the rational ones
we're supposed to be the ones saying to
the children it's okay everything will
be fine don't be scared
instead now the adults are growling put
the mask on put it on put it on you're
scaring me
it's it's cowardice unlike anything i've
ever seen before
it is the most ridiculous and
undignified display i can possibly
imagine
but it's also not all that new i mean
this is par for the course in a certain
way after all we're a country that kills
babies for being inconvenient
drugs children in school in order to
make them cooperative in class
so this is a logical extension of what
we've already been doing
it is then not surprising
but we should be no less embarrassed and
ashamed for it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
by the way you can see behind me um on
the set there the uh my my banjo my
cherished banjo which i play all the
time as you know sitting on top of uh a
couple of books if you want to know what
that's all about you can go to my
instagram page i do have instagram you
can go there and and uh and check it out
uh i don't want to say much more about
it than that i'm not happy about it
that's all i can say
when am i happy about anything let's go
uh number one here
bad news i'm afraid bill gates
whose opinion on covid is supposed to
matter for some reason
uh says that it's gonna be a while
before life can return to normal and
it's gonna be a while before restaurants
can open again he was on with jake
tapper and was talking about it this is
what he had to say
certainly by the summer
we'll be
way closer to normal than we are now
but even through early 2022 unless we
help other countries
get rid of this disease and we get high
vaccination rates in our country
the risk of reintroduction
will be there and of course the global
economy will be
uh slowed down which hurts america
economically
in a pretty dramatic way so we'll have
starting in the summer about nine months
where a few things like big public
gatherings
uh will still be restricted but you know
we can see now
that somewhere between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well
uh to get back to normal
yeah it's it's still not i mean i was
that's a it's a longer clip that i'm not
going to subject you to but i watched
the whole clip
and um it's never really explained why
we should care what bill gates has to
say or why he should have any say in
this
it's it's not even like he he's he's
predicting
what will happen
and that would be bad enough because
again why do his predictions matter but
it's he's just saying he's he's just
saying well here's what we're going to
be allowed to do now and and
by by summer of
next year you can go fully back to
normal
who
says who you
but of course bill gates
has the um has the the ability and and
is his is able
um has the luxury
of sort of sitting back and speaking
about these things oh yeah you know a
few more months well keep the restaurant
shut down you know keep him down shut
down for four or five months maybe maybe
longer
you know because he's a
multi-billionaire
and we should also mention that
microsoft um during this pandemic like
so many other
giant billion dollar corporations
has done very very well they've they've
done record profits especially with
everybody you know moving even more
online doing online meetings and stuff
um microsoft other big tech companies
are doing very well bill gates of course
owns a lot of shares of microsoft and uh
so he's he's recording record profits
he he's making lots and lots of money
and he's sitting there and saying to
to restaurant owners oh yeah just just
stay down just just stay shut down for
four more months
we talked about being a sociopath i mean
this to me is sociopathy
just don't care at all
not even pretending to care not even
pretending to acknowledge
the suffering
that is what
of everything else that's that's one of
the main things that has graded me i
think is great at all of us
throughout this entire thing is you not
only have
people like bill gates and fouchy and
all these other
um
bureaucrats and and and billionaires and
and rich people
not only are they are they pushing for
these lockdowns but they're not
acknowledging at all the suffering
they're just being flippant about it
because to them it just doesn't matter
and again this makes them feel safer
if society shuts down bill gates feels
safer
all right um
speaking of symbolic moves moving on
number two cleveland indians
baseball team are going to be changing
their name um after uh i think what is
100 years over 100 years 105 years or
something they've been the cleveland
indians and now they've uh it's it's
been announced that they're going to
change their name we don't know what
they're going to change their name to
yet
uh i don't think i don't think they've
officially come out with their statement
but this is the report
i think we can pretty reliably say
they're going gonna be changing the name
um
probably for 2021 i guess they're gonna
be the cleveland baseball team like the
like the the washington football team
and why are they changing it because
it's offensive
just the cleveland indians is somehow
offensive
at least with the redskins now i was
against the redskins changing the name
and the main reason i was against the
redskins changing the name because in a
vacuum you know putting everything else
aside
if none of this other pc craziness was
happening
and
it was suggested that just the redskins
might change their name i wouldn't have
a big problem with it
but when you're doing it
in response to
um this this pc tidal wave and you're
responding to the pitchfork mob that's
when i say we can't do it it's just like
we're tearing down statues
of all the statues that have come down
there might be a couple of them
of all the dozens that have been traded
maybe a couple of them you could make an
argument for for taking those statues
down a couple of them
but
even for those i would say in this
environment they should stay up
because even if you can make an argument
for it what i know for sure you
shouldn't do is take down a statue
because the pitchfork mob is demanding
it the pitchfork mob should never get
what they want period
and if they demand it that's reason
enough not to do it
at another time if we can have just a
thoughtful intelligent conversation
about this and be normal civilized
people then maybe you could present your
argument but not in this environment so
that was it with the with the washington
redskins
the cleveland indians though it's just
cleveland indians what's offensive about
that
and of course it immediately brings to
mind the comparison as as people often
do and i have
you know the uh the fighting irish notre
dame
that name's still there no one gets
offended by that but even more than that
because at least that comparison does
come up here's something that rarely
comes up the boston celtics
their mascot is a is a is a
stereotypical leprechaun
nobody ever thinks to get offended by
that
i'm of irish ancestry i'm not offended
by that
i'm not offended by that because i'm a
i'm an adult with a brain
and i know that it wasn't meant in an
offensive way
they didn't put that name on there
because they had some plot to offend
irish people
same with the cleveland indians but uh
you know i did read what cleveland
indian's been around for a long time
the the name they had before the
cleveland indians was apparently the
cleveland naps
naps i don't know why
i don't know where i guess if i if i
wanted to research it i could but i
don't care that much so they were the
cleveland naps before maybe they could
go back to that um i think that you know
that is an appropriate name for a
baseball team at least okay number three
i just want to play this for you uh see
if you can make sense of it
a little bit of word salad on msnbc
mainly i just want to i just want your
help deciphering this so so listen and
tell me if you can if you can understand
what's being said listen
can i just add to that second nicole
because you know in in joe biden's
absence in the years that he's been away
from the senate you know who has been
there vice president-elect kamala harris
who is in the senate even as we speak
and has had a front row seat to the
climate that exists uh in the senate and
and you know it's probably uh you know
giving joe biden quite an update on the
senate that that he uh you know may now
uh be about to to work with or not be
able to work with uh you know based on
the the uh up close view that that and
and involvement that she has had in in
trying to you know see how democrats you
know can potentially work with
republicans she is somebody that has had
direct experience with uh
the exact uh players that that he is
going to have to attempt to to reach out
to and attempt to maybe restore
bipartisanship with uh if anybody knows
the potential for that i think that this
is another potential way in which he can
be an asset to him
got it
did you get that maybe i didn't get it
but i hope you did
i don't know i'll have to run that
through google translate number four the
vatican debuted its official nativity
scene and um this is it you can see some
of the pictures if you're watching the
show right now you can see it if you're
if you're listening um i'll describe it
to you and of course the vatican has
their nativity scene
every year um usually usually quite
quite beautiful
this year not so much and um i'm looking
at some of the pictures now i can't it's
it's hard to even just describe what's
going on here but it looks like
uh first of all just rant just basically
just random objects sitting there
and it i'm guessing that this is
um the virgin mary
with holding the the baby jesus but it
looks like she has a almost like a
an astronaut helmet on
so this is like darth vader and then
there's some weird demon-like creature
in the background
um this won't surprise you learn
is modern art
art
big scare quotes around that uh this is
a
nativity scene these were sculptures
that was that were sculpted in i think
1965 or something
and this is what this is the nativity
scene the vatican is giving us uh modern
art
once again proven to
be uh incredibly ugly and pointless
and sort of revolting
and slightly disturbing
but also you know
maybe one of the main things that
bothers me about modern art is how
sort of cowardly it is uh is it it's
afraid to say anything
it's just abstract and weird and it does
it's not really anything and well you
can interpret it and that's some of the
defenses of of uh the people that have
spoken up to defend this nativity scene
i've said well you know you can
interpret it
interpret it how you want
well i don't want to interpret it it's
you're you're the artist presenting
something to me
you tell me what you're saying it's not
up for me to tell you what you're saying
you have something to say you want to
present an image or something to present
it
but i should be able to know what it is
it should be clear to me what you are
saying it's not about me projecting my
own
uh
thoughts onto onto your
work that's what you get
of course we can't get the traditional
nativity scene where it's just beautiful
images
everybody understands what it is
and we can judge it as beautiful because
we understand what it is
number five the new york times has a new
article uh worth reading maybe you could
check it out it says here's here's the
caption on twitter it says an increasing
number of men
are taking up sewing
not only to break traditional gender
stereotypes but also to advocate for
body acceptance
racial justice
and more sustainable lifestyles
so the headline there is that sowing now
is uh is men have never sowed before
but sewing now is uh is a is a statement
of racial justice
i'm not exactly sure how but uh it does
remind me of a conversation i know i
went to men's warehouse recently to get
fitted for a suit
so i only get you know only only the
classy stuff works for me
and um you know the tailor there was
fitting me for the suit and
i said to him
you know do you are you in this line of
work for racial justice is that why
you're doing it
to break down gender stereotypes and to
make a statement for
racial justice and sustainable living
and he looked at me and he said yes
that's exactly it
and tears welled up in my eyes and we
just held each other and wept
and everybody else in the men's
warehouse was staring
but i'm glad the new york times has
picked up on that the same way that i
was able to
well there's there are a few things that
have more value to your everyday life
than just getting a good night's rest
and if you go through a period of time
where you're not sleeping well maybe
you've gone your whole life and not
slept well because you know you've you
you struggle with insomnia and all that
i know i have it at various points in my
life especially now that i have kids and
if you go through that you know how much
it affects your your day-to-day life and
just your general well-being and that's
why you got to focus on you know being
comfortable when you sleep and my pillow
is the place you got to go for that
everything you could possibly want to
make to make sure that you can sleep at
night and you're comfortable while
you're sleeping you can get at my pillow
starting with of course their pillows
which are just amazing the pillows they
don't go flat
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want and they always maintain
their shape
best of all they're made in the usa
if you don't have a my pillow or know
someone who doesn't have one and would
want one then you can get a my pillow
now it's a great christmas gift as well
uh you could get a queen size premium my
pillow regularly 69.98 you can get it
now for only 29.98 that's a 40 savings
and kings are only five dollars more so
this is incredible savings you can get
for your maybe buy one for yourself buy
one as a gift as well give yourself a
gift give someone else a gift as well
now is the time to buy um not only are
you gonna get the lowest price ever but
they're the best christmas gifts ever as
well again 29.98 for a queen size
premium my pillow buy now and mike will
extend his 60-day money-back guarantee
to march first 2021.
money-back guarantee is a great thing to
have in your back pocket you're not
going to need it though i guarantee you
because you're going to love the pillow
so much go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listener square there you'll find
not only this amazing offer but also
deep discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper and my pillow
towel sets or call
800-651-1148 and use promo code
dailywire
also on the subject of the daily wire on
monday december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw will
soon be available exclusively at
dailywire.com originally released as an
audio podcast for apple and spotify what
we saw will be available to watch as
well as listen to on the daily wire app
uh apple tv or roku app or at
dailywire.com this docu-series takes a
detailed look at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man on the moon if you listen
to this you know how great it is i
listened to it and i thought it was just
uh riveting a dramatically inspiring
story apollo 11 what we saw is a
fantastic series to watch with your
loved ones over the holiday break if
you're looking for something to do
there's a lot of garbage to watch here's
something that's um that the whole
family can enjoy also really educational
on top of it right now get it for 20 off
with code watch when you become an
insider or above member over at
dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to download
subscribe to get 20 off your membership
with code watch and access all of our
new and existing content at
dailywire.com
subscribe all right let's move on now to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
now today for our daily cancellation we
must discuss the huge massive important
scandal surrounding a recent wall street
journal op-ed uh that op-ed if you could
believe it if you even stomach hearing
about it if you can endure the shock
that op-ed criticized
jill biden
shocking stuff yes the big news here is
that
first ladies are off limits again after
four years of melania trump being mocked
and belittled and criticized ruthlessly
even having her you know private
conversations secretly recorded and
published
i can now report
that it is once again sexist to say
anything bad about the first lady
the ring of protection is being placed
around her once more
that this ring of protection only seems
to descend from the heavens when there's
a democrat in the white house is of
course entirely coincidental
uh whether it'll be sexist or not to
criticize the first lady that is
something decided by the alignment of
the planets and the stars it's quite
mystical and mysterious
there is nothing political about it
trust me on this
and that is why this editorial from a
man named joseph epstein has been met
with extraordinary
unquenchable rage here's the report in
variety about it it says the wall street
journal is facing backlash to its
december 11th op-ed that chided incoming
first lady lady dr jill biden and
suggested that she drop the doctor from
her title during her time in the white
house written by joseph epstein the
column states that dr jill biden that
quote dr jill biden sounds and feels
fraudulent not to say a touch comic
contending that because biden has her
doctorate in education
not medicine she should drop the title
the piece also calls biden a quote kiddo
sorry excuse me i'm
i'm so scandalized that she called that
he called her kiddo that i have to stop
and collect myself for a moment
that's rough stuff
that is rough rough stuff
kiddo my god
that piece also just suggests that that
someone should only be called doctor if
they have delivered a child and
undermines the value of her education
but many people on twitter felt
differently and didn't hold back in
expressing their opinions jill biden's
spokesman michael larosa blasted the
essays sentiments and the journal's
decision to run it addressing the wall
street journal's editorial features
editor larosa wrote on twitter james
taranto you in the wall street journal
should be embarrassed to print the
disgusting and sexist attack on dr biden
running on the opinion page if you had
any respect for women at all you would
remove this repugnant display of
chauvinism from your paper and apologize
to her hillary clinton tweeted a simple
yet effective statement her name is dr
jill biden get used to it will and grace
actor deborah messing told the wall
street journal that their hatred for
women is showing and called the whole
ordeal a disgusting display of misogyny
jamal bowman the democratic
representative elect for new york's 16th
congressional district and former middle
school principal wrote that quote the
erasure of dr jill biden's expertise is
shrouded in both sexism and disrespect
for the teaching profession
educators are experts he continued while
we're at it it's also dr jamal bowman
um
and on and on
lots of histrionics lots of tearful
sexism accusations lots of academics
without medical degrees touting their
own credentials
jill biden excuse me dr jill biden did
not address the controversy directly but
did offer this response on twitter which
is being hailed as an epic clapback she
said together we will build a world
where the accomplishments of our
daughters will be celebrated rather than
diminished
and to that i would say yes
we should celebrate our daughter's
accomplishments
we should also celebrate jill biden's
accomplishments
as soon as she has one
for now i must admit i tend to agree
with joseph epstein
jill biden got a doctor in education at
the age of 55.
so good for her
but i'm just not terribly impressed by a
rich woman with lots of time on her
hands and no young kids to care for
getting a doctorate in education
i certainly don't see why i should have
to acknowledge the achievement every
time i say her name
you know you could say it takes a lot of
work to get a doctor in education
i'm skeptical but maybe that's true what
i do know though is that it takes a lot
of work to become a great mechanic
or an expert electrician
there are carpenters with so much skill
and experience that they have reached
the level of master carpenter and yet if
i was a master carpenter insisted that
you address me as master walsh
you'd think i was insane
and that's exactly how i feel about
people without medical degrees going
around calling themselves doctors and
demanding that you address them
accordingly in fact even medical doctors
shouldn't want you to call them doctor
outside the doctor's office a
professional you know similar
professional setting
i can see the need to single out the
doctors with a special title when you're
actually in a medical environment it's
important to acknowledge who's the
doctor who isn't right i don't see any
reason to treat doctors with greater
reverence or courtesy than i would
anyone else in general society though
so even a medical doctor is only mr
misses to me when i see them on the
street
but somebody with a doctorate in
education why would i give any special
notice to that whatsoever
i could sooner be convinced to honor a
you know to to honor someone with a
title uh if they're you know a long
tenured shift supervisor at wendy's
as i find his achievements far more
impressive than earning a useless degree
because you're in your 50s and looking
for something to do in fact
given that the fast food industry has
been deemed essential by the government
maybe all the people in that line of
work can affix essential to their names
as a permanent honorific
actually media is essential too
apparently so i can do the same
my name is lord matt walsh essential
pleased to meet you
or would you be i guess just lord walsh
es in writing the lord part i'm just
throwing in there because why not you
know i mean we could just add whatever
titles we want i guess
i could go buy a plot of land in
scotland or something and officially
earn the title i suppose in the end of
course
it doesn't matter what jill biden calls
herself it's just sort of annoying and
pretentious
the main thing that makes me want to
defend epstein is that all of the most
irritating and absurd people are losing
their minds over what he said
the more they demand
that we call jill biden doctor and cry
that it's sexist if we don't
the more i must insist otherwise
and laugh at their tears
or bottle them in
the handy vessel i have here for such
purposes and that's why all the people
whining today are canceled
dr jill biden is also cancelled
so says i dr lord sir mr walsh esquire
iv
also by the way uh ben shapiro's gonna
have more a lot more to say on uh on
this subject and his wife is a doctor by
the way if you hadn't heard so
uh i'll be interested to hear his take
on on this issue but in any case jill
biden is still canceled i'm afraid
as i said many more cancellations to
come in the future but we'll leave it
there for today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pablo wadowski the show is
edited by danny d'amico our audio is
mixed by mike coromina hair makeup is
done by nika geneva and production
assistant mckenna waters the matte wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. the first
shipment of the coronavirus vaccine
leaves the lab president trump stands
strong on his election challenge and
jill biden's doctorate comes under
attack check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]